we've done a lot of work with two
equations and two unknowns and where
each equation in two variables
represents a line so you're just trying
the intersection of a line but what
happens when you start having three
variables in our linear equation so for
example let's say i had
x
plus
4y
plus z
is equal to
well i don't know let's say it's equal
to 8.
so how do we think about this how do we
think about it visually first of all
let's see if i can graph this so i like
to draw my x and y axes in in the
traditional manner and then have the z
axis popping in and out
you'll see what i mean
so that's my
y-axis
that is my x-axis
and on my z-axis
i can't make it since this is a
two-dimensional format it's hard to do
it but i'll draw it with a little
perspective the z-axis this is the back
you can imagine this is behind your
screen
and now i'm going in front of our screen
or above our screen depending on how
you're viewing it
so that's
that's the z-axis
that is the x-axis and that is the
y-axis so you can almost view this is
the traditional x and y now z tells us
how uh if this was your piece of paper
how much above the piece of paper we are
how much behind the piece of paper we
are so now we're now dealing in three
dimensions
and now something to think about and
i'll answer to you and for you in about
two seconds is what does this represent
in three dimensions does it represent a
line in three dimensions or something
else
well it turns out that it actually
represents
something else it represents a surface
it represents and says since the
coefficients are linear and the and the
um not the coefficients since the
variables are linear it represents a
plane it would represent this big curvy
surface if we had squares in here and
all of that but we're dealing with three
dimension three-dimensional linear
equations so this is just going to be a
plane and let's see if we can visualize
it
the easiest way to draw this
is to figure out the various
intercepts the various uh axis
intercepts so the x-intercept the
y-intercept and now the z-intercept
so what is the x
well let's do the z-intercept first the
z-intercept is when x is equal to zero
y is equal to zero what is z so if this
is zero this is zero z is equal to eight
so that's
this point right here
z is equal to eight
now what is the y intercept that's when
x is zero
and z is zero so if this is zero this is
zero what's y four y is equal to eight
so y would be equal to two
that would be right here y is z that's
zero to zero
right zero two and then no z zero right
there
and then finally let's figure out the
x intercept so y is 0 and z is 0. so if
this is 0 and this is 0 x is going to be
equal to 8.
so that is this right here
now we could draw a line connecting
these
and this wouldn't be necessarily the
graph but it'll help you visualize the
graph of the plane represented by this
three variable linear equation
let me do it in a
in a we're doing a really light color
just so it doesn't
so
there
and in most classes your teacher will
often view this as the graph but i want
to you know you could kind of view this
this will be
and let me see if i can
draw a little bit of
just to
you know hit the point home this is
a surface
so if that's our surface i hope you so
it would be the plane that connects
these three points and these lines right
here you can kind of view them as where
this plane is intersecting with this not
quadrant octant right because we have
four
cubic areas in the back you can kind of
say behind the page and then we have
four quadrants above the page you can do
it that way and so this is kind of the
intersection of that of this plane
with this
with this top
right
up octant hopefully that doesn't confuse
you
but it's important to keep in mind that
the plane just keeps going
the plane just keeps going and a plane
in three dimensions is defined by three
points so that's why it's useful to draw
those three but this plane just keeps
going in
each direction
and this is the best that we humans can
do at graphing a three variable linear
equation on a piece of paper i mean it's
a lot easier if you could do it on a
computer and then you could rotate it
you could see it a lot a lot better so
what does it mean
if you have
if you have let's say you had two
equations like this unless you had you
had this equation
and then you had a
um
let's say another equation let's say you
had
i don't know
x
plus y
plus
three z is equal to
i don't know is equal to three so that
graph let's see the x intercept
would be here it's going to be really
messy now the x-intercept is there at 3
the y-intercept is at 3.
the y-intercept is at 3
and then the z-intercept 3z is equal to
3 so the z-intercept is going to be 1.
so if i were to attempt to draw that
plane at least in this octant that i'm
participating in and this is where it
gets messy
that plane would look like that
and it goes off in every direction
and now if if i had
these two equations
and i have three unknowns what is the
intersection of these two equations or
or what variables satisfy these two
equations so i hope you can visualize it
the intersection between this green
plane which represents by this and our
original plane up here is going to be a
line and that line is going to look
something like this they're going to
intersect right there
there's going to be a line that is in
common between
this green plane and between this blue
equation or that blue plane and that
might be really hard to visualize so
don't worry about it too much if you
find that confusing but this is the best
that i can do
so as we can see if we if we have two
equations and three unknowns we just and
the solution is a line and a line has an
infinite number of points on it so it
still doesn't help us much
but it turns out if we were to throw in
a third a third plane in there or a
third equation and i don't know maybe
it's you know minus x
minus y minus z is equal to zero
and you know that's going to be
something else it's going to be harder
to draw but now that this plane is going
to intersect this line
this line
assuming it's not parallel to one of the
other two planes or it's not equal to
one of the other two planes this plane
is going to intersect the line that is
the intersection of this and this plane
exactly one point
so that's just a long-winded way of
saying that three planes
that aren't the same plane and that
aren't
parallel to each other
will intersect in exactly one point or
another way to put it at if you want
another way to put it is if you want
to solve for a unique x y and z your
constraints have to be three variables
in three unknowns or sorry three
equations with three unknowns so let's
do one of them
let's see
image
actually we're already pushing eight
minutes
this video will be about visualizing and
then the next video i'm going to
actually solve one i'll see in the next
video